[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I prefer to think of a Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where me
and my brother John we answer your
questions give you the beasts advice and
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon oh hey John how
you doing I'm doing fantastic because of
the news from AFC Wimbledon I just can't
get over it Hank but otherwise I'm well
it's a it's a gray cloudy day here in
Indianapolis after several beautiful
days in a row but I am happy my heart is
singing how are you I'm good we are
having weather that could be described
as Taylor Swift Ian and I'm sad that I
have to be inside recording a podcast
right now because I just want to be
romping around in the meadows
potentially just yanking dandelions out
of my yard because they are very happy
very happy dandelions I feel like all
the rest of the plants must look at the
dandelions and and feel really lazy all
the plants out there just being like I
want to do well thing I'm gonna flower
one time and maybe make a seed and
dandelions are like hey by the way we're
gonna do that seventy five times between
the moment there stops being snow on the
ground and and and then well into when
there starts being snow on the ground in
the winter stay Lions they make me feel
lazy and I think all of the rest of the
plants probably feel the same way and I
feel bad for all the rest of the plants
who feel lazy because they're looking at
dandelions
I don't think plants have those feelings
I am however impressed with the success
of dandelion so much so that I wonder
why we have relatively so much plant
biodiversity when you think the
dandelion would have just taken over
completely why why are there any other
plants I feel this way about pigeons and
dandelions that we kind of like we hate
them because of their success yeah and I
just I think that we should I think that
we should laud them and be like what
remarkable well done
adapting to the weird world that we have
created as humans with all of our lawns
and all our buildings and and you know
making it work the wonderful generalist
species of dandelions and pigeons and
humans we have a lot in common no I
agree the only reason that we have so
many pigeons and dandelions is because
we have so many humans so why why do we
complain about these
species for which we are responsible
would you like a short poem for today
let's do it is it about is about pigeons
it's not about pigeons Hank but it is
about feathers oh ok
that's close we've actually had this
poem before on the podcast Hank but I'm
in such a good mood and I can't think of
a better situation in which to read this
poem often known as hope is the thing
with feathers by the brilliant Emily
Dickinson hope is the thing with
feathers that perches in the soul and
sings the tune without the words and
never stops at all and sweetest in the
gale is heard and soar must be the storm
that could abash this little bird that
kept so many warm I've heard it in the
chillest land and on the strangest sea
yet never in extremity it asked a crumb
of me hope is the thing with feathers
also known as poem 314 by Emily
Dickinson Hank have you ever noticed how
hope really is a thing with feathers how
just when you think it's been
extinguished it flies up and leaps in
front of you
ah I mean that doesn't feel like so much
the case for like dag and red fans right
now oh god I do
I do feel terrible for dag and red fans
the recently relegated Dagenham and
Redbridge nobody really knows for sure
what dag and red stands for Hank but
let's move on to some questions from our
listeners before we get to the news from
ANSI Wilden but I think I just have to
say really quickly that the fact that
you're able to name a league to team
although not gonna be a league to team
next year
other than AFC Wimbledon fills my heart
with joy well I also I want to say that
that my club Stevenage which is because
that's where they're that's where
they're working on on on part of the
Mars mission that the ESA is doing is
probably not gonna get relegated but
only barely I didn't know that you had a
league two team are you a confirmed
Steve yeah we talked about it on the pod
could well first off I just want to say
thanks for that fantastic draw yesterday
against Bristol Rovers that was
tremendously important for AFC
Wimbledon's
yeah we talked we talked about it on the
pot Stevenage is the place it's the town
where they're working on the ESA ExoMars
mission or part of it anyway and so I
decided to have my own Ligue 2 team and
and and they are I think currently
fourth from last is that good enough
John that's just good enough to avoid
relegation Hank this is coming ever
closer to me living my true dream which
is to have a podcast with you entirely
devoted to fourth tier of English
football or possibly third tier English
football depending on how things go but
that's for later in the show for now
let's get to some questions from our
listeners all right John we've got a
bunch what what do you want to start
with do you want to start with this one
from Rachel mmm no it's too it's too
stressful
let's do that one second okay okay what
do you want to start with let's start
with this question from Dom who asks
Dear John and Hank John you're a
self-proclaimed Hamilton fan and I am
too but I'm conflicted I feel that
history shouldn't be viewed as a
narrative composed of great individuals
but rather of complex communities
societies and ideologies of course some
great individuals must be individually
highlighted but shouldn't that be as a
bigger raindrop in the storm
although entertaining and educating do
you feel that Hamilton is a protagonist
dependent view of history and if it is
is that good or bad love the podcast
never missed an episode Thank You Dom Oh
Dom Hank this is a great question well I
think that what Dom dislikes is stories
I we gotta have protagonists right we
got to tell stories about history uh
well we do have to have protagonists
within within historical narratives but
we don't have to hold up the idea that
individuals are largely responsible for
making history which is something that
you know Hamilton Yahoo does just
because you know there could there could
be like a massive chorus of thousands of
people singing in the background
representing you know some large body
politic and there isn't I don't mind
that because the music is so great and
also because
the way of looking at history while it
is sort of great man history feels new
and fresh and ex right i I think that
Hamilton is primarily a story not
primarily an educational Enterprise yeah
but I guess the way that we tell our
stories are particularly when it comes
to history shapes the way that we think
about right what humans do and why yeah
I often just think that Stuart that
stories are more shaped by those stories
shape but but first stories are shaped
and stories are shaped by what the kind
of story that people want to hear and
those those the stories that we end up
celebrating because they are exciting to
us and it is a problem that we have as
our world gets bigger and and and each
of us individually starts to feel
smaller that we tell these big stories
about these big people who have who like
have outsized impact on the world or
sort of are the only ones who seem to
have any effect on the world in in in
the way in our storytelling and and
that's that's I feel like it's the
structure of how stories have to work
but because we tell these big global
stories now like you know Steve Jobs
didn't just change you know my life he
changed everyone's life and and
everybody has to use an iPhone and not
everybody has to use an iPhone but like
but there are iPhones all over the world
now and so there's this massive change
that has occurred and you could say the
same thing about Henry Ford the this but
but like by making it global it makes
each individual person feel so much less
significant because all of our stories
become like they're not important unless
they're global and and even telling a
story about a great person who had a
tremendous effect on their local
community always feels kind of empty and
not as sort of epic as it could be
because we have these great epic global
tales that we can tell now and I feel
like it makes all of us I feel like
normal me and everyone feels like a
little bit less appreciation for the
things that they do I and
have I have started to think more and
more about the appreciation deficit and
how we are worse and worse at giving
each other credit for the things that we
all do to make the world a better place
I agree with you in some ways although I
have to say that there are stories
written about people who really choose
to tread lightly upon the earth
including for instance The Fault in Our
Stars which is pretty much what that
book is devoted to in its entirety but
sure sure I think take go ahead and take
some credit there I mean my point was
more than like that's part of a much
larger genre of books that celebrate
sort of moment and that they do do well
but I don't I don't really buy the
argument that we have to be globally
appreciated to have enough outside
outside appreciation to keep going but I
don't know I guess you do and that's
okay well I don't I don't I don't think
that like I think we get enough
appreciation to keep going I just think
think that there's less appreciation for
for the people for all of us who make it
work than there used to be and and I
don't want to live my life in a way
where I do my best to appreciate all of
the people who make my life better and
who make the world better in my normal
life and I I feel the more that I
appreciate other people the more I feel
less the more I feel appreciated because
if I see the the work that is done even
by someone who isn't there like if I
walk by in a new park that's just been
made and I didn't see the people who
made that Park and who planted those
trees and and laid down the grass but I
know that those people happened that
they were there and that they made my
life better and I want to appreciate
them and that makes me feel better about
the world it makes me feel like people
are out there appreciating me and and
that we all work together to make to
make the world work on that we agree
I just don't think that there's anything
particularly new about that let's move
on to another question okay this one is
from Chelsea Hank she writes dear John
and Hank I was in a meeting this morning
with my boss and a bunch of higher up
clients I am but a plebian Marketing
Coordinator
and they were all talking about how
economists are saying America's debt
situation is pointing us toward an
economic depression even more severe
than the Great Depression around the
Year 2031 Nast was the first I'd heard
of such a prediction and in addition to
furious googling I figured I'd to ask
the leading experts on the American
economy John and Hank green is this the
thing I should be actively worried about
should i be saving on my burrito money
in preparation for such a cataclysmic
event well Chelsea if such a cataclysmic
event were to come the good / bad news
is that all of your burrito money would
be worth nothing so you might as well
just spend it on burritos now I also
want to say that Chelsea said the
leading experts on the American economy
Hank and John Green and yet you even
switched it there well I believe that
this podcast should be called Dear John
and Hank and I believe that when people
refer to us they should refer to us as
John and Hank by age not by alphabet all
right uh yeah I mean the hilarious to be
to a certain extent that like yeah this
question is absurd on so many levels
there the idea that like a bunch of a
bunch of people in a room know what is
going to happen to the American economy
in 2031 is itself fascinating to me it
really is around the Year 2031 twenty
thirty one rolls around and the American
economy collapses and everybody can
throw this podcast back at her face but
like yeah that's ludicrous
yeah that's ludicrous I mean for context
fifteen years ago which is how far away
we are from 2031 I remember saying to my
friends why would you ever send a text
message you could just call
I also remember saying to my friends why
would I want my email on my phone I tell
this story a lot John about the time we
were offered a free camcorder from Sony
that record in HD and and and that we
responded to them no YouTube will never
be in HD yeah why would anyone want to
watch youtube videos in widescreen I
believe that was the text of our email
response
ah yeah so yeah to summarize Chelsea no
one knows what's going to happen in 2031
the United States has a lot of debt the
amount of debt that we have actually
isn't very important again please bear
in mind that Hank and I are not
economists but the percentage of our
debt to GDP ratio the size of our debt
as compared to our GDP our gross
domestic product like the total output
of the economy that is considered a kind
of more important number than the number
of dollars of debt itself and our debt
to GDP ratio is is high it it isn't that
that high but most importantly our debt
is very very inexpensive like right now
it's essentially free for the United
States to borrow money because people
are anxious to buy Treasury bonds
because they feel that they are a very
safe investment so we can basically
borrow as much money as we want for free
now that obviously comes with its own
dangers the only real risk to the
American economy from our debt is if our
debt becomes more expensive to service
so like if the interest rate were to go
up which can happen very suddenly and
can sort of spiral that's what happened
in in Greece for instance and in Ireland
is that sometimes your the amount of
interest that you have to pay to borrow
money starts to rise and then you have
to borrow yet more money to pay these
higher interest loans that would be a
problem for the United States economy
there is no evidence whatsoever that
that is about to happen or indeed that
it will happen in 2031 you know I think
that there are legitimate concerns about
our debt to GDP ratio right now but we
don't spend that much to service our
debt compared to you know what we were
spending 10 years ago or 30 years ago so
it's not something that I worry about at
night yeah and I don't think that you
should either yeah I I spent a lot of at
a time looking into this recently
because I was thinking about making a
video on it and then gave up but because
the reason
gave up is because I read a bunch of
different articles from a bunch of
economists that worked at a bunch of
large well-known American universities
and they all disagreed with each other
and that made me feel like oh yeah no
one knows how this works and they're
trying to figure it out and it's an it's
a thing that that experts think about
and that people who are good at this
will will have important discussions
about but it is not a thing that some
some muckety-mucks in a room know better
than like the leading economist at
Harvard or MIT and both of those people
will disagree with each other a great
deal about whether the American debt
whether American debt sovereign debt is
a good thing or a bad thing I got
another question John it's from Rachel
Rachel asks in all caps dear Hank and
John why does writing in all caps feel
so intense like I'm yelling at you right
now why Rachel I actually remember when
all caps became like yelling to me so it
was a specific time in my life it was
the summer of 1993 Hank do you remember
was it was it a similar time for you uh
I don't remember this now so I don't
know if there's a history of all caps
writing being seen as screaming but
certainly when I joined the internet in
the summer of 1993 was the first time
that I'd seen all caps writing being
used to intonate screaming or intensity
and and I remember reading it at first
and thinking well this is silly they're
just writing differently it doesn't
sound like screaming at all and then
slowly over the course of the summer I
was part of this huge message board on
CompuServe over the course of the summer
reading everybody's forum posts and
writing my own I found myself writing in
all caps when I was screaming I found
myself reading other people's capital
letters of screaming so much so that
today or even I remember a few years ago
Hank before our grandmother died our
grandmother only sent emails in all caps
she didn't have the ability to turn off
the caps lock on her on her keyboard and
so I think that it helped her it helped
her see all the world yes
she would write us these very sweet
emails but to me it would just be like
I'm very proud of you for your book
Looking for Alaska I think it's
wonderful that's my answer I think it's
super interesting that we can convey all
of this extra information with text and
we have to find new ways of doing that
like I am a the kind of person who
constantly puts emojis in my emails
because I want it to be very clear when
I'm saying what I'm saying something
that I think is like a sad thing a happy
thing a sarcastic thing a winky face
thing I'm trying to pack in and load in
as much information as possible because
when we're talking as people we have
lots of different ways of showing how we
feel about the words we are saying which
we don't have in text and so we've
developed all of these new cool ways of
conveying that information but I think
you know different people read it
differently which means you can
sometimes have to be careful when you
are sending people emails who are
different ages than you or have
different backgrounds than you because
they like the culture of how to use the
words how to like how to use the tools
that we have on our keyboard which is a
limited set of tools to convey
information accurately is is different
so I will often send an email and then
I'll get a response back from someone
who's you know significantly older than
me that will be kind of defensive and
I'll be like oh I did that thing again
where I thought that that they were
gonna understand what I meant
and they didn't these days think I only
write emails and emojis I don't I don't
use though the letters on the keyboard
anymore I try to only use image based
things so that people have a good sense
of what I mean and with the the variety
of emojis available to us these days you
don't even need text anymore text is
dead my new novel is going to be written
entirely in emoji well I hope is it
gonna be very long oh it's gonna be
extremely long are you kidding me yeah
no it's gonna be like 700 pages oh I've
been working on it for five years what
do you think I've been doing all this
time
I think we've got another question here
from Megan who writes Dear John and Hank
recently from my college geology class
we studied super volcanoes and ever
since I've been extremely terrified
of the thought of Yellowstone destroying
our country and covering it in deadly
ash Oh Megan truly a woman after my own
heart the most alarming thing about this
is that Yellowstone's eruption could
happen anytime and yet I've never heard
of any sort of emergency plan shared
with the population of the US regarding
what to do in this kind of natural
disaster ha ha ha yeah that's because
there's nothing you can do think the US
needs to prepare its citizens for the
possibility of a supervolcano or do you
think this would just cause an
unnecessary state of panic this is a
great question Megan I don't think it
would cause an unnecessary state of
panic I think it would cause an
appropriate state of panic
the problem is telling the citizens the
United States in the event of a
Yellowstone supervolcano except the
sweet embrace of death is not a
particularly in the couraging message I
so first of all I want to take issue
with one of Megan's points which is that
this could happen at any point it
couldn't it couldn't just happen right
now a you know a supervolcano eruption
would have a lot of serious signs that
it was going to occur we couldn't stop
it once we knew it was going to happen
so we would have years of like data
being like it's looking like there is a
dramatic increase of geologic activity
at Yellowstone we wouldn't be able to do
anything about that we would just know
that suddenly there was a lot more
activity there is not a lot of activity
ilist on right now what you would see is
like you would see like rising in the
ground of like like quick like like
meters per day of the ground rising and
that would happen for quite a while
before the eruption itself happened
now when you say quite a while do you
mean long enough for us to establish a
colony on Mars or do you mean like a few
weeks I mean like between those two
things like probably like if you start
to see that level of like and you don't
even know you don't know if it's gonna
happen it could rise and then fall back
down again but it but if you did see
that you might be thinking like okay
there could be something serious that
might happen within the next year within
the next decade within the next you know
hundred years but we're not seeing
anything okay if I can just if I can
just stop you real quick would this end
all life on Earth or would it just end
like human life in the United States
would not end all life on Earth
definitely it probably wouldn't end all
human life and probably not all human
life in the u.s. you know it's just it's
just one of those situations where
you're gonna have a lot of people die
you know the carrying capacity of the
earth will go way down where should I
move in the event that Yellowstone
starts rising and following meters per
day should I move to Australia should I
move to Hawaii I think you're I think
you're pretty good where you are I mean
well I mean you'd be you'd be better off
in Australia okay sure I mean I'll show
these pretty much the other other side
but the the problem is that you want to
be in a place that's warm well as it
happens Australia's lovely so you don't
want to be anywhere that's cold
yeah but but it's not gonna happen and
and in our you know our guesses are that
these things happen you know on the
orders of hundreds of thousands of years
and so it's very likely that that a
Yellowstone supervolcano eruption is is
more than ten thousand years away which
is we've got other things to worry about
in that time oh yeah we're never gonna
make it ten thousand years but in
general that you know a deal it dealing
with a disaster is pretty much the same
with that like with every kind of
disaster unless you are right on top of
the supervolcano which I am in which
case dealing with the supervolcano
disaster is you know just suffocating in
your home just a very short-term problem
yes I got on the question John it's from
Gwendolyn Tom glad that we went to that
extremely dark place Hank it wouldn't
have felt appropriate to get through a
podcast without it all right what's Gwen
doings question I've known for a while
that I would be leaving my job to stay
at home but now that it's obvious that
I'm pregnant people are starting to ask
me if I'm going to come back after the
baby which I'm not as this is my second
child I had hoped that people would just
assume that I was staying around this
time and not asked as it is I've
panicked and started to lie to my
co-workers saying that I'm planning on
coming back I haven't yet told my boss
that I won't be coming back and planning
on staying for another three and a half
months from now and I don't feel like it
would be professional to tell anyone
else before I told my boss in the
meantime it's also not professional with
people to ask but yes yes in the
meantime what do I tell people I don't
want to lie but it's not time to tell
everybody that I'm leaving yet also when
is the right time to tell the boss that
I'm leaving I know that two weeks is the
professional minimum but it doesn't seem
like that's nearly enough time to start
even thinking about a replacement I'm
coming that as a coming at this as a
boss not an employee and I don't know
your boss and I don't know your work
environment and I don't know your your
your you know co-workers and such but
when one of my people is leaving I want
to know as soon as possible and I like
and I don't see a ton of drawbacks to
that you might spend more time training
your replacement and you might get
loaded up with some extra work so that
they can be like ready for you to leave
but I think it's important to I think
it's important to you know leave on good
terms and like you know preserve that
relationship if it's ever necessary in
the future and to get those good
LinkedIn recommendations or whatever so
yeah I mean I think that like I don't
think there's no reason not to be honest
at this point and I'm not sure I think
there's a reason not to be honest I
strongly disagree with yeah yeah okay
you go John
if you live in a right-to-work state and
you say I'm not planning to come back
after I have this child and I take my 12
weeks of FMLA time if you have you know
it outstanding sick leave or whatever in
some states they can just fire you on
the spot so that's why you don't say oh
so so you're saying that there would be
maternity leave that would not get paid
because she's not just maternity leave
but potentially if you say I'm looking
forward to working for another three and
a half months before I take my maternity
leave and then don't come back to work
they could say don't come back tomorrow
ah well I that then that would depend on
on how
you trust your boss and the relationship
you have with them because yeah I would
think like the answer my answer would be
when people ask you if you're coming
back to work you can say the truth which
is that you don't know because who knows
you might not know do you think you know
but like the future is unpredictable it
could be that you have this second child
and like you know three weeks after
you're like man I can't wait to go back
to work so just say you don't know yeah
that's what I would and it is there's
nothing wrong with changing your mind
and there's nothing wrong with even
though now you've made up your mind and
you've lied there's nothing wrong with
lying again and saying oh I changed my
mind I thought that I was going to come
back but it turns out that I'm able my
husband and I or my partner and I or you
know I have figured out that it's
feasible for me to to do this to be you
know to be not coming to work and I'm
gonna do that instead I feel like Hank
sometimes you have an exceptionally like
rosy and optimistic view of work life
because you never had a job right and
because like the way that I run my
office is extraordinarily just like yes
we're loose yeah it's like uncommon so I
think I just think like don't always
listen to Hank when it comes to
questions about work his is his advice
can be kind of doubly dubious although
it's possible that my advice is dubious
too and you're protected by some federal
non-discrimination law when it comes to
that stuff I'm not I'm not sure I'm not
a I'm not an employment attorney but in
general I I'm a big fan of just saying I
don't know to pretty much any question
that I'm asked except that now that I
think about it I am a professional
answer of questions on this podcast we
should probably probably say and I
almost never say I don't know even
clearly I don't know more on the podcast
yeah here we go giving that given that
dubious advice hello it would be such a
it would be a better and also shorter
podcast if we just answered every
question with huh interesting question I
don't know we should probably pick one
question for podcasts to be alike and we
could do it in harmony like I don't know
today's podcast is brought to you by not
knowing not know
lowing it used to be a popular thing but
in the age of the internet apparently
everyone knows everything all the time
including when the world is going to end
twenty thirty one look forward to that
greatest depression of this I guess is
also brought to you by that global
economic collapse of twenty thirty one
predicted in a room by a bunch of people
who are not economists what do you want
to bet most of those people were dudes I
was gonna say dudes but I didn't today's
podcast is also brought to you by the
musical Hamilton the musical Hamilton
tickets available now just kidding
finally this podcast is brought to you
by John's pure emoji next novel yep it's
700 pages of emojis I've been working on
it for five years it's gonna be a work
of blinding genius that will take the
world by storm and no one will ever
think that he's completely lost his mind
truly blinding genius too because it's
hard to read that many emojis right in a
row I believe oh man I also want to say
thanks to our Minh real brought to you
by news thanks to our patrons over at
patreon patreon.com slash dear Hank and
John where you can go and support this
podcast directly if you want to if you
don't want to you can go there and just
enjoy some of the content that we put up
to help you understand more about Mars
and AFC Wimbledon mostly alright John we
got another question we're gonna keep
doing that this one's from Beth who asks
dear Hank and John do you know how I can
explain to my cat how inconvenient it is
when she goes pee and my backpack that
would be super helpful uh you know I
I've been waiting to say it Hank and I
get to say it right now I have no idea
you just you just you don't don't make
anything in your house look like a
litter box it can look nothing like a
litter box make sure that nothing looks
anything like that place and keep the
litter box clean and and stand your
backpack up close it put it on a thing
this is not going you cannot explain
cats how things go but I've had my cat
pee in my backpack it's happened but she
hasn't done it in years because I
stopped leaving it open on the ground
looking like a litter box
duh and like I just like I can imagine
her like getting in there being like oh
this is a nice shape and then like
squatting on down doing her thing like
looking off like thousand-yard stare and
you just lettin it letting it fly right
into I still use that backpack John I
still use that backpack we have another
question this one is from Caleb who
writes Dear John and Hank my name is
Caleb why I didn't heard that gay love
it was right there in the intro but
that's okay is it Ryan as you sure it's
not Ryan some people say Caleb is the
new Ryan um my name is Caleb and I comma
Caleb feel kind of odd in nerdfighteria
because I identify as a Republican
that's over here your sentence I
identify as a Republican I think you
could just be a Republican I don't think
it has to be an identity and I'm a
theist more specifically a Christian I
don't agree with the views they I guess
they is nerdfighteria and a lot of times
you have I however really enjoy your
work and your drive to promote your
beliefs even if they don't line up with
me I don't feel like I'm trying to
promote a theistic no beliefs
specifically Hank as I am quite quite a
religious Christian and and do go to
church and stuff anyway I get enjoyment
out of the things you create which is
why I listen to dear Hank and John in
the first place dang it I didn't say
Dear John and Hank how do I go on and
join what I like in a community that is
always wanting to set me straight yeah I
mean I that that last part I definitely
feel you on and and I don't know this is
this liberating John I love our new
podcast I don't know is the great I
don't know is the new I don't know
either I mean III definitely understand
that idea that like anytime you say
something you're surrounded by people
who are trying to set you straight
and that can be very frustrating I feel
that online a lot like whenever I say
for instance that I am a Christian lots
of people come in to tell me that the
idea of God is ridiculous which I mean
obviously I'm aware of that
thought about it it's not like they're
breaking news to me
but I do think that it's very important
to remain open to other people
ideas and it's very important to be able
to listen and understand where people
are coming from so I I guess I try to
take it as an opportunity to listen to
someone who is different from me and
learn from them and and in that process
try to think about how I can have
participated in more civil discourse so
for instance I have a really good friend
who is supporting Donald Trump for
president which is something that I
totally disagree with right I mean those
of the people running Trump is
definitely the person I would vote for
last and possibly of all the people in
the United States and so it's a really
interesting opportunity for me though to
listen to them talk about why they
support Trump what they feel Trump
represents for them or or you know the
positions that he represents that
reflect their positions and you know it
of course it turns out to be a lot more
complicated than my initial repulsion
would have me believe so I think there's
something some benefit in the act of
listening even if sometimes it feels
like everyone is trying to set you
straight all right right I mean that's
it's it's hard because this is more than
just somebody expressing their opinions
at somebody like apply like trying to
write tell you why you are wrong so it
you know being empathetic in that in
that situation is harder I it but like
you we are in such a mess and I you know
I don't know that this is unique or
anything but it when when a person who
is on the internet all day inside their
filter bubble hears that like you know
that you're a Republican like their
thoughts are not going to be accurate
because they have spent the last you
know like they're sort of like whole
like life on the internet exposed to
only the most extreme viewpoints and
only the and like lots of stories that
have been you know like that
misrepresent that
that you know are you know sometimes
manufactured and just to create that you
know sharper divide between you know our
to our two main political parties and
and so like I think that a lot of people
don't really know what these things
represent on either side and it is very
frustrating and I and I honestly think
that like you know like it's very
complicated there is no one thing that I
that and either these ideologies
represents every person has a different
perspective and it's sort of ludicrous
that we work so hard to try and put
every American into one of two boxes or
three if you count independent and four
if you count non-voter so the yeah I do
think this is difficult and I return to
the fact that I just don't know I mean
the only other thing I would say about
this King hoop is that you also have to
not view the other monolithically right
like you can't view
nerdfighteria as monolithically liberal
when it definitely isn't I mean there
you are not the only Republican in
nerdfighteria you're certainly not the
only Christian and you know it there's
this habit of saying well everything
every community on the internet or every
community or every thing fits in one of
these two boxes especially what in
American discourse that has anything to
do with politics either the conservative
box or the liberal box we even actually
do this with sports right like we all
know that NASCAR is Republican but right
NASCAR isn't Republican NASCAR is a
matter of car taking right turns
possibly left turns out of a very good
sense of direction so it you know we
politicize things that have nothing to
do with with political life in the
United States and so I would ask you to
try to be careful not to do that and not
to apply political labels and political
readings to
every facet of your life we've got
another question
it's from Sam it's a little bit easier I
think but maybe not this is he asks dear
Hank and John a few years back I fell in
love with the TV show now that show is
unfortunately finished finished but I
think of it fondly and as such I find
myself wanting to own that show but was
aghast to find that a DVD release is not
planned anytime soon I was devastated
devastated to realize that I could never
own the show I so love accept that I can
I can very easily buy and download the
entire season legally and watch it
whenever I want to but for some reason
that doesn't feel to me like owning it
there's nothing physical that I can call
mine do you have any advice dubious or
otherwise as to how I can shake this
mentality that I don't own what I can't
see or taught Sam the object is dead
there are no more objects let us let us
disavow all objects and live only in non
physical space let us praise the
electrons that make up the things that
we own and do not own let us escape our
bodies entirely and live only inside of
cyber spacial existences the only way to
protect ourselves from the scourge of
supervolcano's and coming economic
collapses of 2030 right yeah I mean
basically basically what Sam is saying
is I want a DVD so that the American
economy collapse and collapse in 2031
and then in 2032 there can be a super
volcanic eruption I don't want to over
read Sam's question but I think that's
what Sam is saying I mean I go through
this a little bit with books like I love
physical books I'm just an absolute
sucker for them I understand that there
is no way of justifying my love of the
physical object but I still love it but
we are all going to have to become
accustomed over the next few decades to
having fewer objects in our lives and I
think in the long run that's probably
good right I mean there's to me there's
something different about a book and a
DVD because a DVD is a digital file on a
disk and it might as well be on a hard
drive somewhere it's like there's no
there's no difference
from that well okay I don't agree back
by the way just say I disagree with I
disagree with myself too I I have argued
myself out of this but I will say though
this I will change my tack and say that
there's a difference in that I'm never
not going to be able to read a book so I
have a book on my shelf I'm always going
to be able to read that that book unless
there's a fire but if if I don't have a
DVD player anymore which I literally
don't because there aren't like because
it used to be in my laptop but I got a
new laptop that doesn't have a DVD
player then I can't watch those DVD I
like I have a bunch of DVDs and I can't
watch them because I don't have the
system I know you'd have to spend $19 to
acquire a new DVD player I the only yeah
I mean I I guess I kind of agree with
that point Hank but I I mean physical
books are just digital files that are
printed differently so I don't I don't
know can we move on to the news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon and just except
the DVDs are going to have a declining
role in our lives even though I agree
but I wanted I want to tell Sam like I'm
getting the to the root of Sam's issue
is you got to figure out how to apply
ownership to the idea of the thing and
not the physical thing itself and and to
me that's about understanding that that
owning the thing was never about owning
the physical thing it was always about
paying people for the work that they did
to create it and creating an economy
that supports the creation of good
things and that doesn't have like like
the thing you were buying was never the
disc it was always the intellectual
property and you're still doing that
and I think understanding that is less
it gets less viscerally human it's a
it's an abstraction but it is it was
always the case that you were never
buying this you know what was probably a
50 cent thing you were buying the the
thing that existed on it
I agree before we get to the news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon very quickly one
response this is from Jane who writes
Dear John and Hank I'm sitting listening
to your podcast number
III gotta be kitten by the way Hank I do
not approve of that title and I do
believe you owe me an apology I'm on
episode 13 of the first season of
Gilmore Girls and you just spoiled the
whole thing for me I understand the show
is a decade old but I am 16 couldn't
have possibly watched understood and/or
enjoyed the show before now and now
you've spoiled it and this is a great
tragedy of life please contemplate your
contribution to the ruining of my life
this will suffice as an apology I love
it I love the podcast I've been
listening since the first episode thanks
for the dubious advice but no more
spoilers I'm sorry Jane I'm sorry not
least because just now in this very
reading of your comment we've probably
caused some people to go back and listen
to episode 43 more carefully spoil yeah
who otherwise never would have been
spoiled
so I'm doubly sorry Jane yeah I are bad
I didn't mark that I didn't think about
nothing but dubious advice and spoilers
in the show
I initially wanted that question to for
John to not get what the question was
and then for it to only be a joke who
had seen two people who had seen that
but he figured it out and then I then I
forgot to think about the fact that we
were doing anyway I do apologize and if
we're having ruined your life and I I
confirm and you know I affirm that I
have indeed done that and we are going
to have to move on now a very sad ok
what's the news from Mars well you want
me to get this over with quick because
there's I I assume some big news from
AFC Wimbledon's right all right well the
news from Mars is that China who has a
very sort they have a Space Agency it's
sort of arm of their military and it's
very secretive has recently been
changing its tack and has instead of
just like suddenly launching missions
and then people being like to China just
launched a space mission there they're
being a lot more public and they have
confirmed that they are working on a
lunar mission a while ago and just
recently in an interview the head of
China Space Agency confirmed that they
want to be on the surface of Mars with a
rover by 2021
and with that launch happening in 2020
which is very exciting to have another
another entrant into the into the the
exploration of Mars and I'm I'm happy to
have China doing that and and and sort
of feel weird about it because I feel
weird about China and how China operates
as a country but there is this this
interesting thing where space
exploration for a lot of different
reasons that aren't that are mostly
unpure is a thing that that countries do
and and generally they do together and
work together on because it's so
expensive and and when one country has a
problem other countries want to come in
and help them out despite any kinds of
like you know political disagreements
that those countries have so I am
excited for that even though I feel
peculiar about China as a country um
complicated Felix yeah I'm not gonna try
to get into the the complicated world of
uh of Chinese politics I will just note
that I'm excited that there's going to
be a second minivan on Mars AFC
Wimbledon Hank
America's favorite league 2 football
club ahead of Stephen is probably true
probably true AFC Wimbledon the greatest
forth to your football club in the
history of not just England but the
universe since I last shaved tank AFC
Wimbledon has won four consecutive games
here at the very tail end of the league
to season somebody recently commented on
a vlog where there's video John now has
two puffs I do I do I also want to shave
I just can't so I've talked in past
podcasts about our victory over Wickham
and and Plymouth and then AFC Wimbledon
face Crawley Town in the 88th minute it
looked like it was going to be a nil nil
draw the darkness was descending it
seemed certain that Wimbledon would slip
out of the playoff spots down into 8th
or 9th or
possibly even 10th place but then
substitute Auto bio
Aachen phenoix the largest strongest
most beautiful football player alive
today scored a looping header of a goal
victory was ours and then just yesterday
as we're recording this AFC Wimbledon
played already relegated dag and red dag
and red will finish at the bottom of
Ligue 2 and will spend next season in
the semi-professional National League
out of the Football League sadly and AFC
Wimbledon scored two goals they won two
nil thanks to the hard work and goal
scoring boots of that man
the Montserrat II and Messi Lisle Taylor
it was such an exciting game I listened
to it on unrated W do n it was really
great oh really great I'm so thrilled
so AFC Wimbledon Hank now they have four
games remaining almost all the other
teams in league two have just three
games remaining and Wimbledon are
sitting in seventh the final playoff
spot four points ahead of eighth place
Wickham and five points ahead of ninth
place Cambridge United also sitting on
five points back our Exeter City and
Leyton Orient so it's still a somewhat
crowded table but AFC Wimbledon have a
game in hand if they win two of their
last four games they will definitely
qualify for the playoffs I won't lie
Hank that means that if they qualify for
the playoffs they have a 25% chance of
going to lead one but a 50% chance of
playing in the play-off final at Wembley
Stadium and III have I have I am
properly dreaming
I have googled airplane tickets I am
ready to purchase them by the way you're
welcome to come that wasn't a joke
I'm not going to okay well I did just as
well Stevenage won't be in the playoffs
I am so excited this season it's
difficult to describe how unlikely this
is because of course this is the first
year we've been doing
the podcast but you know just just just
two seasons ago Wimbledon had to win on
the last day to avoid relegation or I
guess three seasons ago so this is it's
just a phenomenal situation and I'm so
so excited
it's just crazy hope is the thing with
feathers I'm very pleased and I want to
ask what I think is an important
question not only for you know for AFC
Wimbledon but also for the potentially
our careers on YouTube if they go to the
playoffs does that mean you're gonna
like not shave for like months well Hank
if I am if they don't if they win all
four of their final games and end the
season with eight consecutive wins are
you asking me if I'm going to shave
before the playoffs of course I'm not
going to shave before the playoffs they
will have won eight straight games since
I last shaved
I feel however shave if they lose one of
their last four games okay okay
well let me just tell you I'm hoping for
that but because I want you to shave and
I don't think it will mean that they
won't be in the playoffs and I don't
think they can get into that top three
definite ends up in them in the thing
yeah it's very it's gonna be very very
hard to get into that top three even if
they won out they would only have 80
points and right now the third-place
team has 77 so yeah you're a goal
difference so it's probably not gonna
happen so but that said I still want
them to go go into the playoffs if if
they make it to the playoffs you know on
good form and everything having won a
bunch of games so whatever it takes I'm
happy not to shave I do have to drive
the pace car at the Angie's List Grand
Prix here in Indianapolis the big the
big road course race on May 14th and in
a perfect world I wouldn't have to do
all of the press with a massive shaggy
beard but whatever so is the playoff
thing like I can't cut any of these
hairs or I can't shave like could you
like give you some a nicer looking beard
is that allowed well Hank
obviously I don't know right so that's
the whole problem I don't know which
part of my beard is causing AFC
Wimbledon to win so I can't mess with
any of it John what do we what do we
learn today well we learned that I am a
little bit superstitious it's true we
did learn that we learned that you are
never buying a physical item when you're
buying a piece of media and of course we
also learned that the world is going to
end but probably not in our lifetimes
because of a Yellowstone supervolcano
eruption and finally we learned of
course that John and Hank green despite
the fact that we answer questions for
like an hour every week do not know we
don't know essentially nothing god our
advice is so dubious especially in this
episode I apologize to everyone to whom
we gave dubious advice for for just the
sheer do biasa t of it all but thank you
so much for listening you can write us
with your questions at Hank and John at
gmail.com also your corrections your
complaints about us spoiling
gilmoregirls for you anything that you
want Hank and John at gmail.com or you
can use the hashtag on Twitter dear Hank
and John I'm John Green on twitter hank
is hankering on our preferred method of
social communications snapchat Hank is
Hank GRE I am John Green snaps our theme
music is by gunnarolla this podcast is
edited by nicholas jenkins our
hard-working intern is claudia morales
rosianna halse rojas helps with
questions thank you again for listening
and as we say in our hometown don't
forget to be awesome
[Music]